all right kenny
what's going on mark kenny welcome back
and i'm just glad to be back man you
know the most respected name
in the business i think yeah
so uh mark martinez video which i i shot
at the player's ball last
december
in atlanta
martinez talked about you and just raved
about kenny red kenny red kenny red she
just raved about you for the whole video
well she ain't saying nothing wrong no
all good all good stuff
and it made a lot of viewers wonder what
you're all about yeah
and i think there's lots of explaining
you have to do because
you you know
the first video i did with you was just
short and sweet
so tell me you know you've known
martinez since
i've probably been uh
probably about
maybe about 25 about 30 years almost
what 25 30 years almost you know
yeah martina
martinez uh
one of my
favorite hoes
martina was
martina was a [ __ ] they got money mark
that [ __ ] got money that [ __ ] talks
[ __ ] but you know what i liked about
that [ __ ] she wasn't scary that [ __ ]
go get it for real for real you know
what i'm saying you know i mean
in the game everybody had the ups and
downs we went through our ups and downs
and all that kind of uh uh stuff it
wasn't just all 100 good you know i'm
saying i mean you know it's just like
any other relationship you know what i'm
saying good times bad times or whatever
but you know we came together but you
know what [ __ ] when we parted our ways
and everything [ __ ] we still along on
good terms she's still in love with you
i still hear i hear from her every night
and then uh uh or or either um
or either i'll check on her but oh you
know she'll call my dad like on his
birthday father's day stuff like that
you know what i'm saying yeah
so but but the the pimp and prostitute
relationship is is
it is a form of love i think right yeah
yeah i mean i mean that's what it is i
mean any any hoe that give a cat to his
money until and then have [ __ ] on the
side i have a [ __ ] on the side tell him
oh no i don't [ __ ] her or either oh
that's just a [ __ ] that give me some
money [ __ ] the [ __ ] ain't no food the
[ __ ] got to be a goddamn fool to be
giving her money to a [ __ ] that
go home to a [ __ ] that ain't doing
nothing [ __ ] what's wrong with us [ __ ]
go get up and go to work like everybody
else
i see the reaction to some of my pimp
videos and and i i do a wide range you
know because guys like you and
sharp and the bishop and
tim c these guys are established uh guys
that have been in the game for a long
long time right but they're but i also
do these little hoe hustlers that
they've been called
gang members that have figured out that
this is a hustle this is a way to make
money i mean well i mean well to them
it's just a game to get some money to go
buy some clothes or uh to go buy some
weed and uh uh uh uh you know go to some
of the restaurants go buy some jewelry
to get you know they're trying to go get
the costume together and everything but
then i said they wasn't it wasn't
serious about it though you know what
i'm saying you know the game the game
for us
used to be a way to uh of living you
know it was a shortcut so i didn't have
to get up and go do what the people
wanted me to go do i was on my own i was
in my own time so i had my own offers my
own employees you know what i'm saying
what what is the difference
in
the different types of of these kind of
this way of making money because some of
these guys are just little hustlers and
they're never going to break out of it
and then
but you have to start somewhere well
well what it is well what it is with
this generation and a new generation
they don't listen you know so that's
what number one they don't listen they
think they know everything so i mean you
know but when you got a teacher that's
teaching you that's given to you and
everything you're gonna get it right you
know when people go to school and go you
know graduate from school and then go to
college and get you a bachelor's degree
that's because they have listened you
see what i'm saying but when you have
people that you're trying to tell
something to that's as the same thing
and they don't listen
what they getting up what they get in
class uh if so they fail you know what
i'm saying so but
it take a
oh it really take a a real [ __ ]
one of them want to be in the game
they really want to learn besides just
having a name being a hoe you know what
i'm saying i mean this this the game as
you guys call it is is so misunderstood
yeah by squares a whole bunch of them
and and i'm because i've done so many
video uh interviews with these
prostitutes and pimps and and all these
hustlers i i've learned a lot and what
i've learned is
everyone wants to blame the pimp
but the pimp is not the problem
you could blame the prostitute the
prostitute is going to do it whether
there's a pimp or not
and the pimp becomes her
the basically the the love of her life
because she doesn't really ha it's a
very lonely lifestyle right and they
need somebody who accepts them 100 right
right right and you guys accept these
girls 100 you understand them you're not
looking to change them right well accept
them as they are but but let me just
finish there's one level deeper you can
go which is there's a market for this
there's there's guys that are driving
around trying to get laid
because they can't otherwise
and this is where they go to get it and
these girls have figured that out so the
girls are gonna service these guys the
pimps are gonna help the girls elevate
and get their lives together and be the
man in their life
so it's gonna it exists the the demand
for this kind of
service exists yeah well
well i'ma tell you this here mark
when a [ __ ] can figure out why she
giving that man her money
that's when she gonna become a bad [ __ ]
because she know why she giving she
ain't giving it to him just to be giving
it to him but [ __ ]
why are you giving this man your money
you know what i'm saying i didn't ask
some of these pims watch [ __ ] giving
you some money oh cause i'm because i'm
a pimp and i'm a bad pimp and a [ __ ] no
no it's not that it goes deeper than
that you know what i'm saying ain't no
[ __ ] that's just like me
if it was switched around i'm not gonna
get no [ __ ] my [ __ ] money
without knowing why i'm giving this
[ __ ] my money you know what i'm saying
so you got to know why you you know a
[ __ ] have to be a damn fool and look in
the mirror and be like
well i'm giving this sucker my money and
i don't even know why you know what i'm
saying because i like him or something
[ __ ] you can go keep your money
go find you a man that know about the
game that's going to give it to you the
way that you want it you know what i'm
saying but a lot of these [ __ ] you
know
they like the
matrimony instead of the macaroni you
know what i'm saying so that's why they
get lost you know what i'm saying i had
a female
not too long ago
a young fine [ __ ]
get it i don't mention no names get it
got plenty of money and everything you
know saying and knew what she wants you
know what i'm saying and right now to
this day mark it's been about a year
right now to this day
i re i respect
her gangster because she know where she
want to be at in life you know what i'm
saying and it's like she's been here
before you know what i'm saying so i had
to say so at the same time
versus
[ __ ] that i have had
don't know what they want to be at you
know see a lot of [ __ ] you know it's
like [ __ ] go well let me give him uh
my money oh i'm not happy with him oh
let me go give him my money i'm not
happy and everything the game is so
swishy it's so watered down now you have
to go interview
a female
and then take her two or three weeks
like he's on a job interview to know if
she want to give you her money and she
want to [ __ ] with you i know that but
that's because these youngsters that
made it hard like that you know what i'm
saying they made it like that not like
that so i mean you know me mark i have
females they call me all the time they
dm me call me you don't send females do
you want to get with me i'll be like nah
baby i'm cool you know because you could
tell by females conversations and then a
lot of females they'd be intimidated
because i'm kidding red you know what
i'm saying because i've been here you
know what i'm saying i'm 60 years old
you know what i'm saying mark i don't
bother nobody i go to the gym i ride
motorcycle i have fun i talk [ __ ]
swallow spit the whole nine yards you
don't want to sell i'll just be out you
know what i'm saying but that's what the
what i still sell contributions you know
what i'm saying i'm not a female calling
me hey kevin i want to talk to you you
know what i'm saying but you know what
though but the way it is though now mark
if i can
guide you in a positive way to do the
things that i have seen so you won't
fall down the road different roads that
females have you know say even even the
gentleman allegiance you know i'm saying
have because that's what it's called
that's what pimping is it's a general
leisure pimp is really a gentleman now
it's not like that you know what i'm
saying everybody thinking oh let me go
get a bunch of tattoos oh let me drink
some syrup oh let me smoke this weed oh
let me uh have a snort of cocaine oh
that's pimping that's not pimping pippin
is survival
that's what pimping is people in
survival you know let me get some money
let me do something let me put my money
up because regardless how you still look
at it's still illegal you know what i'm
saying and then you know it's the game
transformed so much you know essentially
they didn't brought the feds in and
this and that the people be watching
people and all that kind of stuff i
don't want all that they can have all
that mark you know what i'm saying yeah
you have a son in prison right yeah i
got a son and pretty i got a son in
prison he got about uh
he got about
five years ago he got about five years
to go
four and a half five years somewhere
together
from not listening
from not listening you know what i'm
saying you know if he would have you
know yeah he was a good dude
i think the charge was probably more
than not listening yeah
hey the charge was he doing what he
wanted to do on his own you know what
i'm saying but he was he was attempt as
well yeah yeah
that's what the girls say you know what
i'm saying but because guess what a pimp
ain't gonna be in that situation you
know what i'm saying i went to prison
for two counts of money laundering
nothing else they can look it up on the
record [ __ ] say what they want
to say about kenny ray i got convicted
for two counts of money laundry wasn't
no 15 year old girl wasn't no taking
nobody across the state line they
dropped all that [ __ ] because because
they knew they was lying yeah sometimes
sometimes they oh they make up these
charges
oh they're going to jack this [ __ ] up
under underage girl over state line is
many years well yeah well she ain't got
to be honest now she can be 200 years
old she's gonna get the same thing
the laws have gotten early yeah yeah
yeah but yeah but mark you know like i
say though if everybody would
sit down there
regroup and you know what i'm saying you
know how you know how like the games
they had to go back you know go back
half time okay come on let's go back to
the locker room let's regroup you have
to regroup mark you can't you you'll
never keep on going four four four four
and i you know what and that's just like
me
i changed with the time you know why
mark because i'm still in the street i
still runs the streets you see what i'm
saying so i changed with the time i
might i could look all kind of different
ways you see what i'm saying but hey
when the people looking at me they know
where to find me guess where i'm at i'm
at home while i'm in the gym
or i'm on a goddamn motorcycle so
goddamn well you know
i heard you say once uh not with me but
with uh another interview you did that i
think you said it this way ain't nobody
in the game ever made any money
nobody you know what i'm saying nobody
you know and then i tell my friends
right now they can say what they want to
say i don't know no rich pimps i don't
know no rich drug dealers and i damn
sure don't know no rich truck drivers
you see what i'm saying so guess what so
even though even though
you take your money and you know what to
do with it but nine times out of ten
[ __ ] we all [ __ ] the money off any god
damn well you know the girls are
tremendously bad with money yeah and
that's why maybe a pimp can help them a
bit but even but but i mean but it don't
take they don't take no [ __ ] that long
to see that a [ __ ] ain't did
nothing with her money if a [ __ ] had
been with a [ __ ] for six months
a year and [ __ ] like that and so on and
so on and they did nothing with his
money [ __ ] he ain't the fool the [ __ ]
got to be the goddamn fool [ __ ] need to
come give me some that money i know what
to do with it
[Laughter]
do you think it should be legalized
prostitution [ __ ] yeah they just the
reason they ain't legalized because
about the politicians just don't want
their wife to know they'd be out by a
[ __ ] that's all [ __ ]
yeah so there's a lot of things that
people do man the politicians by [ __ ]
you see you see how they brought the
[ __ ] up we're trumping them over there
in florida or me or whatever they got to
they got the lady in prison right now
because the other dude he died or
something in prison he got killed or
something right there yeah because every
it is hey everybody name is in the black
book so they don't want that black book
coming out you know what i'm saying a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] like me
would have had that black book of
[ __ ]
dropping boxes of money off at my house
and uh
the
the the hierarchy of girls in in a in a
pimp's stable will be that'll be a
bottom [ __ ]
and she kind of runs the the stable a
bit no no that's a bunch of [ __ ] you
know
no that's where the ones that you heard
from the uh a [ __ ] that's letting
another [ __ ] that run her and she got a
man she in the stable well they got to
be a goddamn fool because in my house
when my house was full or whatever a
[ __ ] couldn't tell a [ __ ] of mine what
to do that's my [ __ ] not your [ __ ] i
don't need my [ __ ] direct you because
if my [ __ ] was telling you what to do
what [ __ ] but you need to go get with uh
with her there because [ __ ] when you
get mad and this [ __ ] tell you to leave
you're going to leave i don't know it
don't work like that i don't know where
to get that from oh my bottom [ __ ] she
ran the house and she told this [ __ ]
what to do i don't know i don't go like
that you know that's a bunch of [ __ ]
that's about jerry springer [ __ ] you
know it's all over the road though
this game is like there's so many people
doing it in different ways
hey it's like um
the [ __ ] that got like bachelor robin's
like 31 flavors you know what i'm saying
but it's just more to it than that and
it gives a game a bad name a a real a
real band i'll be having i i because
there was a time i think i've mentioned
this in another interview that there was
a time that temps were respected in the
community and and they would help people
that were indeed and they would do kind
things for them yeah yeah and
and that was me mark i you know i
couldn't
feed everybody but i never forgot where
i came from you know what i'm saying i
go back to the neighborhood
be on the corner holla at the homies
here go buy y'all this and this and that
and everything go and shoot dice the
whole nine yards and you know the little
kids here y'all go you know saying and
everything you know but now it's just
all about what it is with these cats out
here these cats and these [ __ ]
we got them [ __ ] up because they in
competition with each other and you
don't have to be in competition the only
[ __ ] i ever been in competition
with what's me that's why i outlasted a
bunch of [ __ ] and still here
right [ __ ] now today you know
what i'm saying
but
i'm not going to put myself in
competition my partner master charge i
don't know if i said this before but my
master my partner master charge always
told me don't never be jealous of a
[ __ ] because whatever he got you
could get it or you could get it better
you know what i'm saying that's like me
that's like
me and the pr uh of the president obama
you know obama the same [ __ ] age you
know what i'm saying [ __ ] what i'm gonna
be jealous cause he's the [ __ ]
president cause he got a high power
security cia [ __ ] he got high power
security cia i got high power street
[ __ ] you know what it's like
that [ __ ] you know hey man a
[ __ ] see
and what they do
they prepare themselves
for tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow but
and i know when the bible says don't
worry about tomorrow because tomorrow
has its own trouble but at the same time
you really have to you're really
supposed to a pimp's really supposed to
have yourself put yourself in position
to meet him
that right one that millionaire [ __ ]
that that [ __ ] that really wants you to
have it you know what i'm saying see
that's when you know you're pimping when
you catch you a [ __ ] that really wants
you to have it that's gonna just bring
it all in a u-haul truck like a bricks
truck and everything that's when you
know that you didn't made it me
i'm not finna get off the street i ain't
got a [ __ ] thing i don't give a
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] say not me
they it don't work like that with me i
got my kids and my dad everybody else in
the street that [ __ ] with me i [ __ ] with
them those are my family members i [ __ ]
with them i don't have no brothers and
all that kind of stuff you know what i'm
saying i got a little sister i might see
every blue moon
but as far as
me uh uh uh being like oh well i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do
whatever i wanna do if i wanna go get a
job at home depot i'm doing it just
because i wanna do it not because i have
to do it you see what i'm saying if i
wanna get a job at mcdonald's or at the
legion stadium or something i'm doing it
because i want to do it not because i
have to do it you know what i'm saying
you're not going to make me do something
that i want to do but i know one thing
these girls
they forget that they're getting older
you see what i'm saying okay
that's like with me i'm 60.
now you take another [ __ ] you take a
[ __ ] that's 60 years old put it on the
side of me and see who's going out last
who
is she gonna go is she going to be able
to catch youngsters
or am i going to be able to catch the
youngsters you see what i'm saying
nobody want a [ __ ] [ __ ] with
no titty sagging that way down here to a
goddamn lap and and tattoos uh tattoos
used to be real tight now the
[ __ ] drooping down to her
ankles you know what i'm saying that
[ __ ] [ __ ] better stay in the gym get
right in tight you know saying and and
and have a plan it's all about having a
plan if you don't have no plan
it's over
and one of the most interesting things i
heard from one of the other pimps is is
this i've heard this more than once they
you want a girl who wants you you don't
want a girl that you like
yeah you're looking for a girl who likes
you yeah i believe yeah believe that
yeah yeah believe that you know what i'm
saying but see now i mean you know it's
so much competition now you know saying
[ __ ] my girl got a girlfriend you know
you know this change right yeah man to
change for real hey in your face
the world changing people face and
people don't even see it you know what
i'm saying did you stay up with all the
technological changes huh you stay up
with all the like the internet and all
those kind of new channels yeah yeah but
you know what though mark i never really
i never i'm not no computer i'm not
savvy on the computer so i really don't
even worry about you know i got kids or
something if i need something really
looked up and i can't do it i'm hey you
know what i'm saying you know saying
somebody you know that's down with all
that [ __ ] though other than that though
[ __ ] i ain't still no goddamn computer
no no i'm just you know mark you know at
our age mark guess what we're doing mark
it's a job it's a job to live though now
it ain't like it used to be when i was
young mark well we didn't think about oh
[ __ ] my number is getting is coming
sooner or later see people don't know
see when i turn 50 mark
50 was like oh okay but mark when i
turned 60 i was like whoa you don't say
it baby like whoa you know what i'm
saying my i'm 60 years old i ain't got
time for the police to be chasing me i
ain't got time for no [ __ ] to be called
no police on me which that ain't never
happened to me in my career you see what
i'm saying because i didn't do i didn't
do [ __ ] wrong like that like martina
said i took care of my [ __ ] i have
lawyers and bills by them i don't give a
[ __ ] if i went out of town or or off a
[ __ ] went across the country somewhere
if a [ __ ] and i was in jail a [ __ ] was
getting out i ain't had i probably had
my out of out of
my uh out of my career i probably maybe
had
one maybe two [ __ ] that wouldn't deal
some time but it was on something that
they did not not not something i sent
them out the dough to do it's something
that they did you know what i'm saying
but now these [ __ ]
have warrants you know what i'm saying
because the man ain't got no money here
took the money
uh [ __ ] it off in the strip joint you
know what i'm saying you know what that
but you know one thing i never
understood delmar
how do [ __ ] accept
giving their money to a [ __ ] and
they know that they man going to the
strip joint to make it rain on a bit i
never got that you see see that see
martina she wasn't away for that and
and i'm saying and i'm saying the reason
she wouldn't have went for it because
the [ __ ] ain't no damn fool it take a a
a a silly ass [ __ ]
to let her man take the money and make
it rain because they think that's cool
ain't nothing cool about that that hun
them two or three hundred dollar stacks
of ones that y'all [ __ ] up should i
take that money go do something else
is it sometimes the fact that the girl
never had
a good role model in her life of like a
loving relationship and so she's used to
being treated badly by by her dude
know what it is you know you know what
it is more
it's cause [ __ ] be feeling sorry for
they self you know what i'm saying [ __ ]
ain't got to feel sorry for themselves
you know every everybody all of us got
the same color blood and all of us got a
brain
if you don't use this [ __ ] that's the
residuals you get out of it you get
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying but if
you use it you're gonna make i know some
i know some chicks
some pretty high power chicks that's in
the game mark the halloween business hey
hey they get money all that mark you
know i'm saying and
back then a long time ago
i wouldn't even talk to this [ __ ] mark
especially if [ __ ] wasn't with me but
the way it is with me and these females
is respect any [ __ ] that i ever had
mark if i see the [ __ ] and she with
somebody i'ma still speak whether the
[ __ ] speak or not be like hey how you
doing because you know i appreciate the
things that you have done for me you
know what i'm saying
yeah you haven't made a lot of enemies
it sounds like no no you're very
positive yeah
hey hey mark you're one of the most
positive dudes in the game i've seen
well hey that's what i try to be because
i'm not talking about i know i know some
cats they talk to you about again if you
talk if you talk to them about the
pimping it's like it burned their
[ __ ] ears off because they weren't
successful in it though you know what
i'm saying [ __ ] that it is what it is
mark you know i'm saying and that's how
it is dog you know you you can't be mad
at nobody if you did if you
didn't advance in life from the from the
game you can't be nobody you can't be
mad at nobody but your own self
you know what i'm saying that's just
like with some of my
uh uh uh uh uh uh ex females i have had
mark i wish them well hope they're doing
good and everything you know what i'm
saying i have a few ex-females that i
that you know they still call me they're
not doing all that hot and everything
but
by them you know the things that they
have done for me by them if they needed
something i got it mark i got to send it
to you you see one if i got it more i'm
gonna send it to you you know why
because guess what you made sure i was
straight you know what i'm saying and so
and i made sure you were straight when
you was with me but when you broke off
from me and went with somebody else and
even though we then got older
we all we got still
see at the end of the day we all we got
still right now we all we got
and see people don't value that because
they look at oh tomorrow oh oh hello oh
he oh watch that
you know the cool part about mark i got
haters that comment on my page but if
you feel like it's about me why do you
be on my page
get off my [ __ ] page you know what
i'm saying
i'm not following you i'm not your
friend you know what i'm saying
because i have a youtube channel that
gets the same kind of reaction sometimes
i believe the the negative comments are
really fueled by envy yeah yeah you know
you know why my because
they be mad because they can't be me you
know what i'm saying that's what most
like
you know what mike i had to do some dude
hit me
talking about oh uh yeah you you was in
prison you was a [ __ ] and i i was like
you know what but you know what what i
didn't i didn't i didn't dm about and dm
back or uh or hit him back you know why
mark because it's like arguing with a
ghost you know
no yeah that's all
i'm gonna talk to [ __ ] face to
face you know what i'm not gonna argue
with a [ __ ] that i can't put my
hands on you see what i'm saying
yeah no nothing yeah i'm so [ __ ] a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] that talks
[ __ ] about you and all that kind of [ __ ]
is a [ __ ] that's seeking
attention yeah you know what i'm saying
and you ain't gonna get it from me
because i'm not gonna respond to a
[ __ ] that i don't know and then
and i'm not gonna go back back and forth
texting you wasting my time on the
telephone you i'm not hard to find i got
the same cell phone in mind i had 22
[ __ ] years i'm not hard to find what
i love about you is is that your
positive your positivity and your
integrity yeah you appreciate more than
anybody i've seen yeah i appreciate that
yeah
is what your integrity makes you
yeah
yeah i said like sometimes you know i
look at sharp stuff i look at bishop
stuff but see if everybody if everybody
see that
you know
we are similar in some ways but we all
have our different styles you know what
i'm saying
it's not too much that
we have a disagreement you um you know
what i'm saying it's like the military
they got their codes you see what i'm
saying the streets they got their codes
yeah see that's that's the thing a lot
of squares don't understand the streets
yeah not that i'm any genius right but
i've learned that the streets have this
very different code that's right and and
squares are just like oh no you're a
pimp so you must be evil when in fact
what you are is a companion for these
girls and and these
somewhat polygamous relationships
need a man you know what delmar i have
met females since i don't got old i
don't know i mean i don't know they say
that you know you get old you get soft i
say no you get older you get you get
more wiser you know what i'm saying and
so i i had um
i met a meta female
and she 23 years old mark
fine [ __ ] boy
and i know i could have just did
whatever you know what i'm saying
and she told me that you know she was
going to school the things that she do
and everything i say you know what baby
that's a blessing keep on i say you know
the direction that you want to go see
mark when i if i meet a female
and i know the direction that you're
going mark
i'm not going to stop you from going
that direction you know what i'm saying
mark i'm not going to try to talk you
out of going through that direction but
you know you know what i tell a female
now just don't forget about me
you know i'm in the street if i need a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich i might
have to stop on your door you need to
knock on your door i might have to try
to get in contact with you just feed me
that's all you know what i'm saying
don't leave me on the street you know
what i'm saying i mean kenny red says
fine yeah it's a whole other level of
fine yeah right yeah that's a whole
nother level yeah yeah yeah you guys say
fine yeah when you say fine i've seen
i've seen these girls like
yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying so you
know market then like i said you know
and it is you know saying man life is
more
serious to me life is you know saying i
try to be more positive i don't want to
be like
uh the people you know i hear
[ __ ] over here still getting a
bunch of money but you still over here
complaining though you know saying one
thing i know i told my kids when a
[ __ ] got bills
you living especially when you're able
to pay him when you ain't got no bills
that can't pay them you're not living
you know what i'm saying but you know
what though mark
the bill collectors they call me
and be like uh yeah mr wright um
you got such and said okay well i ain't
got it what you gonna do jump through
the phone kick my ass and i okay i'll
have people change their phone that's
why i never change my phone number mark
i'm not changing my [ __ ] phone
whatever these people gonna do looking
for me or whatever i'm not changing my
phone number because i ain't got it i
ain't do it so now what you know what
i'm saying that's it that's all yeah
oh i changed my number because uh baby
was over there tripping people be
calling me and said i'll be like what
the [ __ ] is that all this stuff i say
man i'm not locking your phone on me you
change the number too much who's it oh
no baby maybe would you oh no you know
man i got time falling hey man
[ __ ] better start living home
and if [ __ ] gonna be in the
game a [ __ ] better treat the
game right you know what i'm saying
uh uh it's just like being on a
motorcycle the faster your bike goes the
more you want to show out dweller but
you better respect that [ __ ]
because if you don't you're going to go
down but what is what is the game what
do people in the game need more is it
compassion and kindness no no no no what
people what people need more
in the game is
to listen
take heave and know that's for real
especially
when you talk to somebody that's then
been through it my [ __ ] don't
know i haven't been through the ring of
homie in the street i have been through
the ups and downs oh you know what
though i was talking to mike yesterday
mike epps is a personal friend of mine
he was on the phone for about 30 minutes
mike you know if i need something i
could call micah i got a few friends
like a car but me and mike we had a long
serious talk yesterday you know what i'm
saying and you know he said
can you read
i appreciate that you always be my big
brother he said i needed that you know
we talked about life you know what i'm
saying we talk about no money we talked
about health
not nowhere we talked about health life
you know living leaving things for your
kids your generation you know what i'm
saying and everything you know i got my
own generation but guess what so it's
still my job since i'm still running the
street to try to leave something behind
you see what i'm saying or something
like that you know my i got a my ex-girl
i told her i said you know what
you're doing good you got you a cool
dude he handling all your shits hey
appreciate it you know what i'm saying
see my see mark people don't appreciate
see welcome to the appreciation of
things you know what i'm saying what
happened oh i appreciate him you know
[ __ ] look at me oh no he too old uh
what's up but guess what though mark
that don't bother me i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] let me
see how you look in 20 years from now
because i'ma still be the good lord said
the same i'll still be in the gym
pushing that [ __ ] up you know what i'm
saying [ __ ] know they go on my
instagram the real kenny read and see it
you know what i'm saying yeah what would
you say is the most important thing
you've learned in your 60 years
the most important thing that i have
learned
[Music]
is to live mark is to live and
you know i don't want to be looking
behind my back respect you know what i'm
saying love and respect you know i was
taught that love and respect love
the word love and respect and if you
abide by them you're going to get it
back
you can't go wrong
you know what i'm saying i love respect
that's like you i respect you
[ __ ] to say i say chickasaw i
say
mark
does what he does because he like doing
what he doing he don't do it just to do
it he like
mark give [ __ ] chances and
everything and you could call him and
he's going to talk to you and everything
he's not
hollywood marcus hollyhood he might be
walking but he's good though too you
know what i'm saying you know i know
mark you know what i'm saying but at the
same time though man
i just want
the youngsters
to remember one thing remember this
youngsters
you're gonna get old and if you haven't
done nothing
and for and preparing to get old
and everything you can't be mad you
cannot be mad they go for the women i
don't give a [ __ ] how much surgery they
go get they're not going to look like
that 20 30 years from now you see what
i'm saying
hey gravity gonna be then took over and
all that you see what i'm saying so
they better use it before they lose it
you know what i'm saying and to all you
pimps
or you want to be pimps or don't know
what direction that you're going in
take time out to reevaluate yourself man
you know i'm saying because
when you pimping you don't have to show
nobody that you're doing it when you
pimp it it's going to show anyway
especially when you're doing it right
you know what i'm saying get your
respect off the street it ain't about
the uh
the uh
rah-rah and fighting and what you gonna
do to this person i'm doing that you
know it's all it's all love it's all
love man you know what i'm saying and
then you know if a [ __ ] can't go
from that [ __ ]
they're headed for self-destruction
[ __ ] gonna self-destruct whether
they know it or not you know
yeah it's all about reevaluation you
know and i want to say hey
martina
you always going to be my girl i
appreciate you and everything you know
what i'm saying but at the same time
martina i don't know i know you got a
lot of haters and all that kind of [ __ ]
and everything but you know i just want
to say one thing martina i appreciate
everything you didn't done for me and
everything and i know that you a real
[ __ ] and all that kind of stuff and
everything you know i'm not going to go
into the details what everybody want to
hear until they make a movie about me
and you because we we was like uh i can
tina turner you know i don't say that
and everything well you know martina
keep doing your thing baby i appreciate
it she's gonna get you and martina in
here together oh yeah yeah yeah yeah she
ain't gonna mind i ain't either
all right thank you very much yeah
that's great
you